Trascrizione: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
(Applausi)
Io sono un po',
non emozionato, perché stare in questo salone
mi dà un senso di vertigine tutte le volte,
pensare che un luogo così bello
dove hanno camminato e vissuto
alcuni tra i più grandi, oggi ospiti noi,
non voi di TED che siete naturalmente i benvenuti,
ma noi amministratori di Firenze,
mi dà il senso di una vertigine e mi fa sempre domandare
se nel rapporto tra passato e futuro
possiamo trovare una chiave per ragionare di ottimismo
oppure la definitiva consacrazione del pessimismo cosmico di questi giorni.
Vi dico subito la mia tesi.
La mia tesi è che l'ottimismo sia fondamentale per la politica.
Ma non l'ottimismo inteso come
"Speriamo che le cose vadano bene"
Non l'ottimismo inteso come
"Vabbé, accontentiamoci!"
Ma l'ottimismo inteso come straordinaria forza vitale
secondo me è fondamentale per la politica.
Sguardi perplessi.
Tirate fuori "Il Sole 24 Ore" di giovedì scorso:
"Fate presto".
Questo dovrebbe essere l'elemento che richiama l'ottimismo.
Perché? Perché questo titolo era il titolo de "Il Mattino" di Napoli
il giorno dopo il terremoto, il terremoto dell'80.
E "Fate presto" è il titolo del giornale di Confindustria
per dire "Signori, qui sta succedendo un casino di proporzioni immani."
O intervenite adesso, o non riusciamo a salvarci.
Come si fa a essere ottimisti quando in questo parlamento
in questa consigliatura, in questa legislatura
ci sono stati più cambi di casacca -- 164 cambi di casacca --
che non proposte di legge approvate dal parlamento.
È un dato di fatto, è un numero.
Pensate che ci sono stati 164 cambi di casacca
e 121 parlamentari che hanno cambiato casacca.
Perché qualcuno l'ha cambiata più volte,
perché bisogna anche abituarsi;
cambiare idea è segno di intelligenza,
qualcuno in parlamento è veramente un genio.
Allora, io credo che parlare di ottimismo oggi
significhi tentare di vincere la mucillaggine
della banalità, della volgarità, anche dello squallore.
Credo che si debba essere ottimisti.
E non giocando alla meno.
Vi racconto, per me, dove ho imparato.
Avevo una professoressa alle medie che tutte le volte mi diceva
che bisogna accontentarsi nella vita.
Alle superiori sarebbe stata la classica tipina da 6-
e credo che se noi non diamo occasione alle nuova generazioni
per uscire dalla filosofia del 6-, non andiamo da nessuna parte.
Quello che all'università prendeva il 17 e due figure.
Dobbiamo uscire dall'idea di giocare tutti
soltanto alla meno.
L'ottimismo per me, nella mia esperienza personale,
ha iniziato ad assumere un significato bello, positivo
quando ho incontrato un uomo --
l'ho incontrato solo metaforicamente perché
non ho mai avuto il piacere di incontrarlo --
che si chiamava Dietrich Bonhoeffer.
Dietrich Bonhoeffer è stato un martire del nazismo.
Era un pastore luterano
che fu ucciso a Flossenbürg,
20 giorni prima che finisse la guerra.
È drammatico. Ovviamente ogni morte in guerra.
Ma quando sta per finire... Quanta letteratura c'è
sul dolore che è terribile ed è drammatico come sempre,
ma particolare quando tu te ne vai proprio nei giorni finali,
quando sta per arrivare la primavera,
quando sembra che tutto volga al bello
e improvvisamente tu non puoi far parte di questa pagina nuova.
Dietrich Bonhoeffer è stato tra i sostenitori
del tentativo di golpe contro Hitler.
Ha scritto un libro bellissimo che secondo me andrebbe portato nelle scuole.
Perché andrebbe fatto leggere, anche se è molto difficile,
e si chiama "Resistenza e Resa" e dice
dell'ottimismo -- dà questa definizione dell'ottimismo:
"L'essenza dell'ottimismo
non è soltanto guardare al di là della situazione presente,
ma è una forza vitale,
la forza di sperare quando gli altri si rassegnano.
La forza di tenere alta la testa quando sembra che tutto fallisca.
La forza di sopportare gli insuccessi --
ecco il pezzo che mi piace --
una forza che non lascia mai il futuro agli avversari"
Il futuro lo rivendica a sé."
Vorrei dirvi perché, secondo me, la politica oggi
ha bisogno di non lasciare mai il futuro agli avversari.
Ve lo dico qui in questo salone, che è un salone del passato.
Oh ragazzi sveglia,
laggiù, Leonardo da Vinci ha dipinto quello che Vasari,
l'ha detto Maurizio Seracini prima,
ha considerato il più grande capolavoro di Leonardo,
più bello de La Gioconda, più bello de L'Ultima Cena.
Noi pensiamo che sia lì sotto, lì dentro,
andremo a scovarlo e lo troveremo, spero,
non è che si può farlo dipingere a un madonnaro, va trovato.
Ma è l'idea che questo salone abbia un passato forte.
Pensate che qui, in questo stesso salone,
lo diceva qualcuno prima,
non soltanto si è giocato il rapporto tra Leonardo e Michelangelo --
lì Michelangelo avrebbe dovuto rispondere con la Battaglia di Cascina --
ma in questo stesso salone Cosimo il Grande
ha immaginato sé stesso.
Laggiù c'è una tartaruga con la vela, il simbolo del "festina lente",
lì in quello studiolo, Francesco suo figlio giocava con i giochi alchemici.
Pensate a Vasari.
Vasari che in sei mesi fa il corridoio
partendo di lì, arrivando agli uffizi
e poi arrivando a Palazzo Pitti.
Sei mesi oggi, un'amministrazione non fa in tempo
a mettere neanche il timbro del progetto preliminare
della conferenza dei servizi della valutazione di impatto strategico.
Questo è un palazzo ricco di storia.
Qui si è riunito il parlamento, qui si riunivano i grandi sindaci delle città capitali.
Però qui, noi vogliamo rivendicare il futuro.
Come? Tre esempi.
E vi dico tre esempi che hanno detto tre amici che hanno parlato prima di me.
Tre fiorentini.
Ne cito tre perché sono tre che qualcuno ha citato prima.
Il primo: Ser Pippo.
Sembra una nocciolina da fumetto.
Ser Pippo era Brunelleschi.
Brunelleschi, i fiorentini lo prendevano in giro.
Non gli credevano, lo consideravano un matto.
Ma voi vi immaginate i fiorentini?
Noi siamo fatti -- chi di voi è fiorentino lo sa --
Questo aveva l'idea di fare la cupola a modino, tutto una cosa particolare.
I fiorentini lo prendevano per il culo costantemente.
Immaginavano che lui non potesse
riuscire a raggiungere il risultato strepitoso che poi avrebbe raggiunto.
Ma Brunelleschi è un grande uomo ottimista.
Non perché spera che domani vada meglio.
È un grande ottimista perché ha il coraggio di non mollare
quando gli altri ironizzano su di lui.
E la grandezza di Brunelleschi
non è soltanto nel fatto che la cupola del duomo
è il luogo dell'incontro tra Dio e il suo popolo.
Bellissima questa immagine.
Il luogo più alto della città.
Per chi ama la laicità,
la cupola del duomo in qualche modo accompagnava
il luogo dell'assemblea
perché il Duomo era stato costruito perché potessero stare dentro
tutti gli abitanti di Firenze.
Era la vera grande piazza civile.
Brunelleschi è un grande
perché dopo aver fatto il luogo dell'incontro tra Dio e il suo popolo,
dopo aver fatto il luogo dell'incontro della comunità
va a fare il Salone degli Innocenti.
Cioè il luogo dove i bambini venivano abbandonati,
il luogo dove i bambini venivano esposti
e una mano -- le suore li salvavano
e li portavano in quello che era l'Istituto degli Innocenti.
Questa è la grandezza di Firenze.
Quando la bellezza tiene insieme la solidarietà.
Quando la bellezza tiene insieme l'attenzione all'ultimo.
La più grande bellezza di Firenze è che il fatto che tu ti preoccupi
dell'arte e della cultura, ma sei capace di stare attento al dolore di un bambino.
Ser Pippo Brunelleschi ci insegna l'ottimismo.
Ci insegna l'ottimismo Giorgio La Pira.
Lo diceva Rodolfo.
Quando a Firenze ancora i sindaci erano persone serie,
Giorgio La Pira era capace, non soltanto di portare qui con uno sguardo profetico
i sindaci delle città capitali
perché lui riteneva che Firenze fosse capitale.
La Repubblica Fiorentina era capitale; guardate La Pira in mezzo alla gente.
Per lui Firenze era la capitale della Repubblica Fiorentina
e quindi qui portava il sindaco di Mosca,
piuttosto che i sindaci americani,
nel momento in cui c'era la cortina di ferro.
Tiravano sui il Muro di Berlino, qui si costruivano ponti.
Ma Giorgio La Pira è stato un grande perché
ha sempre pensato che l'ottimismo in politica
non fosse soltanto la profezia di un mondo lontano,
ma fosse la capacità di tenere insieme lo sguardo sul mondo
con la cura del quotidiano.
Per lui atto più rivoluzionario era fare la centrale del latte,
che è ancora del comune di Firenze,
perché portare un bicchiere di latte ai bambini nelle scuole nel dopoguerra
era un grande investimento sul futuro.
Perché Giorgio La Pira, con Meucci che prima ricordava Rodolfo,
era uno che s'era andato a mettere insieme
i principi della carta costituzionale, che Lorenzo ci ha letto
a partire dal primo articolo,
con i principi del diritto romano
e le leggi dello stato postunitario.
Mettendo tutto insieme cosa faceva?
Dava le case a chi non le aveva.
Allora non c'è ottimismo possibile, seconda figura di riferimento fiorentino,
senza l'attenzione e la giustizia sociale.
Questo è un paese nel quale sta crescendo troppo la diseguaglianza.
La diseguaglianza non può essere
semplicemente combattuta lasciando le cose come sono.
Sono i conservatori quelli che non vogliono cambiare.
E che magari dicendo che bisogna difendere gli ultimi
non si rendono conto che allontanano profondamente --
che alzano lo spread;
non finanziario, ma lo spread tra i nostri sogni e la realtà.
Terzo punto. Terzo grande riferimento fiorentino.
Me lo fate vedere?
Ma questo è Walt Disney, non è fiorentino.
Captatio Benevolentiae verso Jovanotti.
Pinocchio è la cosa più fiorentina che ci sia.
Non è soltanto il secondo libro più tradotto al mondo dopo La Bibbia.
Ma Pinocchio è fatto da un signore che si chiamava Carlo Collodi.
Carlo Lorenzini -- Collodi era il paese della sua mamma --
che è sempre vissuto intorno a Firenze.
Il paese degli acchiappa-citrulli era Firenze.
Guarda che sindaco che hanno! Per forza, è vero.
L'acchiappa-citrulli era Firenze, così come il Paese dei Balocchi.
Così come tutte le strade.
La fatina era una signora che è morta nel 1964,
una bambina di 13 anni dai capelli turchini.
Allora Pinocchio perché è Pinocchio?
Pinocchio ha un grande valore tra i tanti.
Pinocchio è uno che sa fallire e può ripartire.
Noi oggi viviamo in un tempo nel quale, in Italia,
sembra che fallire sia il marchio di infamia,
sembra che fallire sia una totale delusione.
Si può fallire, ma il vero marchio di infamia
non è fallire, è non provarci neanche.
Il vero marchio di infamia è lasciare stare a guardare
che gli altri ci provino, mentre tu stai a giudicare.
"Non ce la farà mai."
È non mettersi in gioco e pensare che tocchi sempre a qualcun'altro.
Per me l'ottimismo è l'essenza della politica.
E lo dico in questo momento nel quale può sembrare strano.
Qualcuno potrà considerarmi un matto,
ma l'ottimismo significa stare dalla parte dell'ammirazione
e non dell'invidia.
È una cosa diversa stare dalla parte dell'ammirazione anziché dell'invidia.
L'ottimismo significa stare dalla parte del coraggio. Davvero.
Dalla parte del lavoro contro la rendita.
Dalla parte della sfida contro la paura.
E io penso anche che l'ottimismo
abbia tante piccole cose concrete, piccole conseguenze concrete.
Per me ottimismo significa pedonalizzare il centro di Firenze
perché il suono del silenzio che fa la pedonalizzazione
è un valore straordinario rispetto al frastuono di una sgommata.
Significa aprire la Biblioteca delle Oblate fino a mezzanotte
perché se tu vuoi non essere soltanto carne da Auditel
hai bisogno di luoghi fisici, non soltanto virtuali.
Anche se poi credi che i social media
possano essere la grande rivoluzione del nostro tempo.
Essere ottimisti significa dire
che fai le quote paritetiche tra donne e uomini
non perché te lo chiede la moda
ma perché credi che senza il potere dell'intervento delle donne
non andresti da nessuna parte.
Non abbiamo tempo, ma questa città deve tutto a una donna,
l'elettrice Palatina. Altro che monumento.
È una storia talmente bella che la racconteremo un'altra volta.
Io credo nell'ottimismo perché facendo il sindaco
quotidianamente mi rendo conto che i bambini e le bambine
che vado a incontrare il martedì mattina nelle scuole
sono la più grande risorsa e la più grande ricchezza.
Il Maggio Musicale Fiorentino mi ha chiesto:
"Vieni a fare Pierino e il Lupo?"
Ormai lo fanno cani e porci, hanno preso anche me a fare Pierino e il Lupo.
Ho fatto Pierino e il Lupo e come forse qualcuno di voi sa
si inizia chiedendo ai bambini -- ce n'erano 2000
al teatro comunale -- "Posso raccontarvi una storia?"
È l'inizio, è l'incipit.
È stato bellissimo perché ho detto:
"Posso raccontarvi una storia?"
Più di 1000 bambini hanno risposto "Sì!".
Finché i bambini delle nostre città
avranno voglia di farsi raccontare una storia
e noi saremo capaci di raccontarla senza stare dietro
al cinismo degli adulti, ma tentando di mantenere in vita le loro aspettative,
io credo che ci sia uno spazio per l'ottimismo anche in politica.
Allora, ho finito. Volevo farvi vedere un video, ma l'ho fatta troppo lunga
e quindi non lo faccio (è un'informazione di servizio a chi doveva fare partire il video).
Noi stiamo vivendo una fase molto particolare
anche nel nostro paese.
Non sappiamo quale sarà la pagina nuova che scriveremo.
Credo però che sia importante passare
da un modello culturale a un altro.
C'era un modello culturale che era quello sintetizzabile in un'espressione:
"Ci penso io."
"Dammi una delega, lo faccio io per te."
"Hai un problema, te lo risolvo."
Poi si può discutere se i problemi siano stati risolti o no.
Ma c'era questo modello culturale: "Lascia fare a me."
Io credo che sia arrivato il momento di dire
che l'ottimismo in politica imponga a ciascuno di noi, di voi
di poter dire "Io, con verità e con libertà."
Dal "Ci penso io." al "Tocca a te."
Tocca a te. Tocca a te che magari non sarai geniale
come Ser Pippo Brunelleschi.
Tocca a te che non sarai fantasioso come Carlo Lorenzini.
Tocca a te che non sarai innovativo come Leonardo da Vinci.
Tocca a te che non sarai capace di profezia come Giorgio la Pira.
Però tocca te.
E se tu non sarai in grado di metterti in gioco te,
nessuno lo farà al posto tuo.
Questo è il motivo per cui quando il momento è più buio
credo che la politica abbia più bisogno dell'ottimismo.
Nel dire a ciascuno di voi, a ciascuno di noi,
a ciascuno di noi qualsiasi sia il nostro lavoro: "Tocca a te."
Non c'è più il "Ci penso io.", c'è il "Tocca a te."
Se ci rimettiamo in gioco, ciascuno cercando di fare bene il proprio lavoro,
l'Italia sarà un pochino più bella
e se l'Italia è un pochino più bella,
il mondo è un pochino più ricco.
La dico in questo modo:
l'ottimismo in politica significa costringerci a un'evidenza;
e l'evidenza è che questo paese è troppo bello
perché la pigrizia ci porti via.
Io tutte le mattine che entro in questo palazzo
mi sento sopraffatto dalla bellezza e dallo stupore.
Voi siete qui da 4 ore, probabilmente vi è già venuta noia.
Ma se noi riusciremo a non farci sopraffare
dallo stupore e dalla bellezza,
l'ottimismo che riguarda ciascuno di noi sarà in grado di trasformare la politica
e anche forse di evitare che in parlamento ci vadano
schiacciatasti e cambibandiera
e invece ci vadano persone più serie.
In bocca al lupo a tutti noi.
(Applausi)